good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday hope
everyone had an amazing
active fun blessed weekend i know i did
i know you did yes we both really had
such active fun and blessed weekends
we were like literally just spreading
this genie vibes transatlantically
yeah continentally much better word yes
thank you continentally
considering neither of us trans the
atlantic i didn't
no you didn't cross the atlantic you
crossed the continent transcontinental
transcontinental she went to las vegas i
went to las vegas for 15 hours you guys
i'm so dead
no regrets because like i said i don't
know if i've mentioned this to you we're
living in a post-pandemic world
do not look for me i don't want to be
found so it was a lot but i had so much
fun you know hanging with the gals
and i'm broken on the inside but i kind
of look like stunning today so
it's that sweater that's a really great
color for you the pleni vibes always
just bring out the brightness in
everyone i agree and i know you guys are
thinking there is a heat wave hitting
the eastern seaboard why are you wearing
a wool sweater
our studio is freezing freezing so it's
really hard for me to dress like
as someone who walks to work in an 82
degree and climbing heat
but who also sits in an ice box for an
hour no it's so crazy and i got the
weather this morning from weatherman
snitch
i don't know if you saw her instagram
stories but she was letting everyone
know the weather which i actually found
really helpful
so i dressed for a heatwave like sort of
just wearing a matching short set you
guys will see it in the post
um but yeah now i'm cold and hot at the
same time
it's really rough we're sending love to
anyone who is experiencing this heatwave
i was watching the local news last night
before the olympics because i was like
so excited we're gonna talk about it
don't worry and
oh my god they were like really like
fear-mongering like it is really scary
of course because like power can go out
and heat wave and it's really not
healthy for you know people to be
outside for that long so
i'm just taking the advice of my local
news anchor and i'm staying inside yeah
and i know that's gonna be really hard
for you as someone who's so like i said
active
and outdoorsy outdoorsy yeah i really
it's gonna be hard for me but i do think
i need to do what's best
for my body a hundred percent so
don't forget to stay inside and con ed
is like really everyone's just
fear-mongering like it's a heat wave
it's not a hurricane like
everyone all the texts like we're
preparing for an outage in your area
like
chill chill oh i didn't get any texts
like that you didn't yeah
no there's something about the local
news will have you fearing
everything no and when you live in new
york right now like it's just not the
best time for new york like lots of
crime there was a literature shot in
times square yesterday like
it's really easy for the local news to
make you feel scared because there's a
lot to be afraid of you don't have to
try very hard
no they just have to report the news
literally
literally um well i'm glad to hear you
had a good weekend i did i mean i
went to vegas and then i literally got
back on friday so i had like the whole
weekend ahead of me you know
yeah that's a great amount of time to
recover so i landed at eight o'clock
and i went home i showered i got into
bed
my chicken teriyaki arrived and i
watched night one of the
u.s uh women's olympic trials for
gymnastics
and i swear to god i don't think i've
ever been so happy in my whole life wow
there's something about when you're
someone who's really a homebody pre
covered post covet during coven
there's something about when you are
forced to leave your home and then you
make the return
it's i can't even i don't even know if
there's an adjective to describe it it's
joyous no and it's absence makes the
heart grow fonder like you're always
fond of your home but then when you
leave
and come back it just hits that much
harder like i wish for you
all like the happiness that i felt in
that moment like clean hair
i had like it was a big trip and i was
excited about it it was a lot of work
you know six hours there six hours back
it was all behind me yeah and that
glee i don't even know the word it was
so splendid
i think it's really a contentment on par
with inner peace
i feel like contentment is like
satisfaction it's it was beyond
satisfaction it was literally like
miraculous
magical like i don't even know the word
wow that sounds amazing i had the
opposite experience when i returned home
yesterday because i was so [ __ ]
unwell like this migraine just took hold
of me
grasped at my brain and still hasn't let
go
and it's just so unfair it's so
important and it's like
why are you being punished i don't know
and having a good time like i barely
drank like you know
grandma of the weekend and i don't think
anybody suffered as much yesterday
yeah as i did so now i'm starting to
think like maybe it's not necessarily
alcohol is just like physical exertion
but i'm a
pretty like active outdoorsy person do
you get a migraine when you do like a
peloton run
no no i don't know i i definitely
have some you know what i have some a b
testing today it sounds like a case
for a doctor and i have a doctor it was
just like
it wasn't my time you know i'm so sad
i'm so sorry but yesterday i started the
redheads book because episode drops on
thursday the nature of that fragile
things by susan meisner and
all the redheads have been chatting
because we're all reading it and we all
love it
so good it's it's a win and i'm happy
for bex because it's about her choice
and she's had some rough choices when is
the d'andra's choice
coming up on the podcast deandra will be
choosing
next month yeah cool okay um also i
started malibu rising on the plane
i was just like not in a place to read
like i just i couldn't get through like
i got through like two chapters like it
was good like if i'm not in a mood to
read like you
know even the best book in the world
even you know the art of war like
nothing could make me want to read if
i'm just not in the mood
i understand but so you weren't in the
mood i don't know
no not at all and i brought my kindle
all the way to vegas for like literally
nothing your kindle weighs point zero
zero zero three pounds
um it's it was annoying because i also
had an ipad and even though my tsa
pre-check if you have two electronics
like you have to take one out so it was
like it was a burden
okay sounds like you're being dramatic
yet again 100
and also like say you had been stranded
like no wi-fi like you would be so glad
you had your kindle it's for emergencies
that's true that's true
um so what percent were you in malibu
rising oh i don't know
oh just curious because i finished that
it was really good but i think i already
said that it's definitely good but
it was like a turn up weekend like what
am i doing with my kindle no i
understand
but sometimes you know contrast is
everything everything yeah
we have an amazing show for you guys
today of course we have the fast five
we've got to talk about the olympics
i also have a lot to talk about in tv
recap because i did bring my ipad on the
plane and i started the new season of
too hot to handle
and i finished the entire season of
working moms and i just had like a lot
to say
okay i almost started the new season of
too hot to handle but it's episodic
and i just feel like those cliffhangers
are going to get to me and i want to
watch it all together it's so annoying
but we'll see like i've been seeing a
lot of stuff about it so maybe
maybe i'll watch episodically you never
know well they dropped four episodes
it's not like they dropped one oh
yeah oh okay yeah i was on the second
that was that wasn't clear to me it said
new episodes weekly like i
think one a week i think they batch it
like a week oh that's cute
okay so maybe is is it as good as season
one um
yeah okay yeah okay it's it's a great
show
i'm sorry i didn't mean to ask you i
didn't have a question you know what i
get it so confused with love is blind
like i really do and to me like even if
the next season of love is blind is so
good
it's never gonna be as good as that
first season because
the mark and the jessica like there was
just so it was so good yeah
and then i got confused for a second but
um too hot to handle
is good no matter what they always they
they just cast like really great people
yeah okay cool i'm excited my content
plate is run it's over but i feel like
i've been catching up on the content i
really do
me too and as of this week like i'm
gonna be really good catch up on all the
content i'm so behind on like new york
housewives
but then i'm also gonna take on this
journey of love island starting today
right
i oh i don't know if it starts today but
today or tomorrow i love love island
i just want to be a part of something
you know and everyone's watching it you
will definitely feel a part of something
because it's on every night and so like
you'll never feel alone i know that's
that is a lot yeah every night like
saturdays and sundays no
it's like five days a week okay i think
it starts sundays they take off like two
days whatever
okay you'll figure it out yeah i'm also
so behind on shots of sunset but
whatever things happen things happen
people change there's so many shows out
there
so many shows yeah um and we have all to
talk about all them we do have to talk
about all of them but before we get into
the fast five i just want to send
love to everyone in surfside in miami
the building
that collapsed there i've been following
it all weekend it's such a sad tragic
story
it's really really upsetting and it's
like what are the
it's like the most one-in-a-million type
of thing to happen it's so horrific
and so i just wanna i like i've been
praying yeah just thinking about it so
much and so we would be remiss if we
didn't mention it
it's so sad and every time like i
checked for an update it's just like
there's no good news no no there is not
but we're super hopeful praying for a
miracle the mexican and israeli like
special forces have arrived
i'm just hoping that it helps yeah it's
really sad but
we're gonna do what we do here and take
our minds off of it for a little bit and
deliver
the fast life stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
sorry i'm just running my tongue over my
smooth delicious brushed teeth
oh yeah yummy feels so good um so
i'm assuming today's episode is brought
to you by bruce why would you say that
because you just mentioned it and i just
want to say so i got um
the new bruce in the middle of the mob
which leaves me now with two brushes
so i have a travel brush now that so i
don't even have to unpack
so i brought my travel bruce to this
weekend and not only was like my
sickening mauve
bruce just like sitting there waiting
for me really glamorizing the rental
i felt like so orally
sounds superior yeah due to having a
bruise this weekend so happy for you
like my
dental hygiene did not suffer for one
second as a as you would think it would
on a girls trip well today's episode is
brought to you by bruce and if that
wasn't a sell
enough i'll sell it for you more the
brush is the best electric toothbrush on
the market one because it works
so well very effective and two it is the
most affordable a lot of electric
toothbrushes can go up to 200
which is a little nuts but the brush
comes with six unique modes to customize
your brushing experience
the battery life lasts four weeks it
comes with a magnetic charging stand and
like jackie said a very compact travel
case
they also offer a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again
they'll ship your new replacement heads
for every six months so you're never
stuck using a worn down brush head
the design is very sleek it's modern
aesthetically pleasing and it comes in
trend driven seasonal colors
and it looks great on your bathroom
counter get 15 off your bruce toothbrush
kit and the refill plan when you use
promo code toast at bruce.com
that's 15 off using promo code toast at
brush.com
sign on be orally superior i really like
to organize sound better
okay you could be orally sound oh okay
but then you're superior to me that's
true because you're just sound yeah
that's true
okay our first story such exciting news
the us olympics gymnastics team 2021
tokyo olympics has been announced last
night
was the final night of olympic trials
and we have
simone biles sunisa lee jordan childs
and grace mccallum
will compete as the team while jade
carrie and michaela skinner
also known as kaylor skinner will
compete as individuals at the tokyo
olympics and also in watching last night
for this olympics they changed the way
that they chose the team usually they
choose like
five and you wouldn't compete for like
you wouldn't
have a trial for like just to be an
individual so they switched it up for
this year and they already didn't like
it and they're going back to it for
paris in four years but this is what how
it will be this year
okay i mean i watched friday and sunday
like i'm so invested i think everyone
knew that
simone biles was of course going to come
in first in the trials and was no doubt
going to
tokyo um suny like literally this
weekend was kind of all about suny lee
she is sickening like
talk about someone who just made no
[ __ ] mistakes like so consistent and
there was actually a lot of mistakes
being made
uh simone fell off the bounce beam
a lot of people fell off the bars
somebody couldn't finish
emily lee couldn't finish her floor
routine because she like face planted
like
there was so like i do
usa and they said this like on the
telecast a million times now still
eugene
was one of the uh broadcasters but she
was sick she was so good
um they basically said like if you're on
team usa like you're pretty much
guaranteed to win a medal like usa is so
dominant in women's gymnastics
so i'm not worried about the team but i
did see a lot of flops and i just think
they're going to camp now and like we
need to tighten up
some of those loose ends i agree but i
would also
i'm happy as i say judgmentally for like
i know it's like you can't critique
any sort of olympian like as we just
like sit on the couch like we can't even
walk to our studio
we're the laziest people 100 but i i'm
i'm glad not glad but i feel like if
everything was so on point and perfect
at the trials it kind of like leaves
you know for things to go wrong at the
olympics so if they're going to make
mistakes
i'd rather do it in the trial a hundred
percent
simone was actually she did like a post
competition interview and she was like
super disappointed in herself like she
didn't perform at the level that she
wanted to but she still came in first
like that's just what happens when
you're
so elite like top of your game best in
the world like i'm really not worried
about simone the execute like the
difficulty scores are so high that she
has so much
room to for error forever because she's
already performing at like just such a
different level and she's kind of like
the ali raisman of the last olympics
because
ali razon was like the grandma she was
the one who had been before she was the
oldest
and simone was like that's me now like
i'm gonna impart wisdom on everyone but
what's interesting about all the girls
is michaela skinner
who the last olympics made it as an
alternate and
never got to compete and i think that
was like devastating for her because it
was kind of like the end of her
traditional gymnastics career and she
went to college to compete
and then decided to try one last time
and she got kovic she got pneumonia like
she's been through a lot
um and she made it as an individual and
she's 24 which is
obviously very young but i think in
gymnastics like it's like modeling like
you have a very short
span of when you can compete at that
level yeah and her story is kind of her
last chance her story was really
interesting and inspiring also simone
biles is 24.
yes so simone biles was like i'm the
grandma yeah but michaela skinner hasn't
competed in olympics yeah yes so then
there were also four alternates so it
really did feel like a lot of the people
that you saw like are still going to the
olympics
they're getting on the plane yes but a
lot of them won't even be touching the
tarmac you know
yeah yeah no they'll touch the tarmac
but they're not the targets touching
that the floorboards
yeah the vault yeah yeah yeah um yeah
also what i found to be so
sad and i didn't realize was that the
parents can't go to the olympics this
year
there was because of the coveted band
like they're not allowed to
travel to the olympics so they have to
watch from home and i just think that
that is like
horrible so wrong so many of the
olympians are so young
and like they oh that's really upsetting
really really like for so many different
reasons like for the parents who have
put their whole lives
on hold but like for 20
years like do you know how expensive it
is to train someone right and get them
the pinnacle of everything you've been
working for you don't even get to be
there you have to watch
from home like us oh which is everyone
should get at least one person
their mom like for the girls competing
like some of them are really young and
like to travel internationally
on your own especially like knowing what
we know about
uh us gymnastics and how they don't
protect the girls
like i'm not really not here for this
decision no you're right and there were
like girls i don't know what the minimum
age is but there were girls competing
who didn't make the team but could have
who were like 16.
yeah i think at that point you have to
have a parent travel with you
right they didn't say anything about
that that's crazy i didn't even know
that
yeah so let's go through everyone who
made it because of course mobile's like
we knew she was gonna make it the goat
suny lee was like really a star and i
feel like she will bring lots of glory
home
for our country jordan chiles was making
me hysterically cry like she was just
she's that's why ben was like why are
you so obsessed with watching the
olympics i'm like because you're
literally watching people's dreams come
true and like jordan chiles
is the epitome of that like she almost
gave up in 2016 she was just like over
it
but she continued and like now she made
it and she was like so happy and her and
someone are like best friends you like
train at the same facility like
it was so cute and so inspiring and like
she's like
all these girls like they're such good
role models for young women like
it was so inspiring and when she cried
like i was crying
yeah no she and she did amazing like
every routine i only watched last night
not friday night every routine was
so on point and i think even though she
was she came in third and only the top
two were confirmed to go like
you know like the announcer said like
jordan's got going so it was really the
fourth spot that was like who will it go
to
it was really between michaela skinner
and grace mccallum grace mccollum had
like two
one thousandths of a point higher um to
be honest i watched both nights and i
don't even remember much about grace
mccallum she was just kind of like
consistently
good that's what you like to see yeah so
she was probably like a really good
selection i'm sure michaela skinner
wanted that
position but at least she got one she's
going and the more the merrier
i think it worked out really well that
we have like six girls going
and then four alternates yeah jade
carrie who was the second individual
spot earned that spot like
months ago yeah she won like a national
title and she won all these different
competitions that basically guarantee
you that one of the individual spots
so she was like competing these last two
days pressure-free yeah
must be nice must be nice because you
could tell a lot of the girls were like
quaking and really some of them buckled
under the pressure oh my god it's so
much pressure
oh my god i can't even imagine first of
all you're in a stadium that was full
20 000 people so that in and of itself
is scary you're also being televised
on basic cable even more scary then
what's at stake
literally for a lot of girls this is
their one and only chance to make it to
the olympics and after this they're just
gonna you know
move on with their lives i was thinking
last night and obviously you know i'm no
olympian so i can't say but i
actually think that olympic trials might
there might be even more at stake than
the olympics because
once you're at the olympics like you are
an olympian i think and and
you know you're there to just like perf
i mean obviously to win but to perform
and have fun and it's like
but to imagine working your whole life
to work to be at the olympic trials and
not make it to the olympics like your
journey ends here
i would think that there's more pressure
to just get to that olympics i thought
the same thing i think that the trials
are definitely scarier because once you
make it to the olympics you are
officially an olympian for life
and of course you're gonna try your best
and do your best but there's definitely
i think
less pressure a hundred percent yeah i
wonder like if any you know olympians
are out there
emma yeah we have one toaster olympian
who's going
um too us know if the trials you think
have more pressure than the game well
there was also a lot of drama in the
track and field
kind of harking back to where we were
talking to earlier the heat wave
they postponed it three hours because
they were not gonna make people run
it's happening in i want to say
oregon okay and it was like 112 degrees
so they of course we're not going to
make the athletes run puts them in
danger
so they ended up pushing it back like a
bunch of hours so that sucks i imagine
you're so geared up to like try and go
to the olympics and then like you have
to wait four hours
yeah yeah yeah that does suck so that is
the olympics coverage
we of course will be keeping you abreast
on all olympic things um this is your
reminder to order your red white and
blue outfits like from amazon and stuff
like um
because the olympics is almost here yeah
almost here really
really exciting i'm glad that i watched
last night too like now i have i'm
familiar with the girls their strengths
what we should be looking out for yeah
and um
i've been watching a lot of track and
field i know i mentioned that to you and
honestly
it's so crazy to me that like the women
run in underwear
and like i just i haven't been able to
stop thinking about it like like they're
fully wearing underwear
yeah and i guess it makes sense it's
like the most aerodynamic it's like a
speedo like a really tight
pair of undies i just can't get over it
no i know because like that would never
happen for you or i
no to run no and like if you want me to
run like you've got to give me like a
pair of
anti-chafing biker shorts 100 and then
also what i was thinking is like the
gymnast to me
i think and i'm not putting down other
athletes but i do think
as as far as olympic sports goes gymnast
gymnastics is the most difficult one
because
you're not mastering one sport you're
mastering vault bars it's four
it's just i don't feel like i need to
explain myself i feel like it is the
most
difficult olympic sport and they're
wearing full glam like i couldn't get
over it like they were wearing eyelashes
their hair was in like these fancy
braids and yarns and
gold eyeshadow and i'm just like damn
like if
if i have to do something like really
seriously like i can't wear any makeup
like i can't explain it like no i was
actually thinking about the glam and it
must be really fun
like for them to be able to express
themselves in that way like and i feel
i feel like the glam will actually even
be stepped up at 100
the olympics you know and i just i think
that's a really fun
way to express yourself i just i don't
think like i
kept like you're on television of course
you're gonna wear makeup yeah but like
i just felt like some of their buttons
were not secure and it was like making
me nervous because i'm like if that was
me i would
literally need an entire bottle of gel
and like 8 000 elastics
some of the buns were stressing me out
because they also felt like a little
like floppy flop
yeah like bouncing back and forth but i
think you know for the girls it was the
best button for them
you know i'm i trust them that they're
securing their buns i was just like that
does not look secure
yeah no i i feel you i really am looking
forward to see the hair and makeup
um they should do it themselves i do
i do think they do it themselves because
they want to feel like themselves
yeah maybe not in tokyo though like they
are focused on
i don't think they have hair and makeup
well yeah if their parents can't come
hair and makeup can't come
a hundred first time i would hope not
yeah
um so we'll obviously keep your breasts
um i don't know what other trials are
coming up but
i'll find out and i'll and claudia will
let us know the olympics report doesn't
stop here don't worry yeah but it's not
full olympics coverage until you have
pink eyes
[Laughter]
totally okay you ready for our
gotta go fart on my pillow lol theo
could do it for you 100
you probably already definitely
definitely are you ready for our next
story switching gears into system
lullaby
to some celebrity news sure cardi b is
pregnant
expecting her second child with husband
offset there's another baby on board for
cardi b
and offset the rapper announced on
sunday that she's pregnant with their
second child sharing a nude photo of
herself
covered in white paint and cradling her
baby pump hashtag number two
i'm sorry number two hashtag
like because the hashtag well actually
there's really no way to know what she
meant
yeah was it number two or was it pound
it was a tic-tac-toe you never know
see when i saw this i was first so happy
for her because i just love cardi
but then i was also confused because i
was like we went back and forth so many
times with
cardi and offset breaking up getting
divorced separated getting back together
that i got like the chloe interested
effect and like i no longer like kept up
with
whether or not they were together so
yeah if you had asked me like two days
ago our car to be an offset still
together i would have said i have no
idea
so i guess this was her way of letting
us know they're still together and
they're expecting a child and i think
that's wonderful
love to see a growing family yes and
they performed at the bet awards
and she showed off her belly oh that's
cute that's like one of my favorite
pop culture moments of all time yeah is
when beyonce performed love on top which
is such a
stunning song like and i actually feel
like as a society we don't really
talk about that song enough and then
beyonce performed it and opened her
blazer and she's like a little baby bump
and it was just like
kind of like the most stunning thing
i've ever seen in my life um and this is
very much giving me that type of energy
yeah definitely great energy to be
giving off yeah
um i actually go back on youtube and
like watch that video like maybe once a
year
oh that's good yeah annual re-watch you
know how like when you're
you go down like a youtube rabbit hole
there's like five videos you like always
watch
yeah that's one of them um fifth harmony
like
right after they graduated from x factor
before they had like their own original
music
they used to put out these covers on
youtube and some of them are
so stunning they did a cover of read by
taylor swift it's
gorgina they also did a cover of ed
sheeran's
lego house so each video like a
different girl chose the song you know
oh cute so camilla cabello was the one
who chose
lego house and then like she kind of
made it like her thing and i forget i
feel like it was maybe ali
who chose red by taylor swift they're
all really good i recommend you going
down that rabbit hole so that's kind of
where i start
we're all really good i think we're all
choosing really good songs
um so everyone has like that playlist of
things and that beyonce one is
definitely also beyonce's singing in the
back of the car
in her documentary listen from
dreamgirls that's also on my list
nice okay cool maybe you should share
your playlist what's on your list like
do you have like a go-to youtube rabbit
hole
like not really i don't spend as much
time on youtube
as you i'm so sorry no you're missing
out don't be sorry i'm sorry i'm sure if
i i thought long and hard about it like
there's definitely
um moments and like music moments that i
do tend to watch often but i'm being put
on the spot
okay i can't think i also watch all too
well performance at the grammys that's a
really good one oh that is a good one i
love a super bowl
that's always i would say that's my
annual rabbit hole to watch like all the
best super bowl performances
that's a really really good answer thank
you thank you claudia that's really
sweet you're welcome
are you ready for our next story sure
something that you personally wanted to
talk about
yes i'm ready for this this was a
claudia request it's the weirdest story
ever
courtney love accuses olivia rodrigo of
copying whole
album cover she says it was rude of her
courtney love is accusing olivia rodrigo
of copying the cover of holes
h-o-l-e's 1994 album lived through this
for a promo without giving her
credit the famed cover features a prom
queen wearing a tiara
tiara and holding a bouquet of flowers
celebrating her big win as mascara has
smudged below her eyes from crying
rodrigo's image shows her wearing a
tiara holding a bouquet of roses and
traces of mascara running down her face
okay i hadn't looked at the two
like no doubt they're similar i really
don't think olivia rodrigo copied
just hold on okay courtney love then
posted this side by side
on her instagram with the caption like
spot the difference
pound twinning pound twinning yes then
olivia rodrigo commented like
yes like lived through this photo it's
like one of my favorites whatever
basically
agreeing that it was a source of
inspiration oh okay
to which courtney love wrote the
weirdest response back is it in that
article
you have to read it it's so funny but uh
not no then courtney love was like
responding to people's comments on her
face okay
this one olivia you're welcome my
favorite florist is in notting hill
london dm me for deets i look forward to
reading your notes basically like you
should send me flowers
stop my favorite florist is in notting
hill i'm looking forward to reading your
note
oh my god so at first people were like
at first i thought her post was kind of
innocent like look me inspiring the
youth like so cute yeah
olivia's comment was so cute i thought
it was all good and then that comment
made me realize like she's butthurt
about this
and then i guess that instagram post she
also shared to her facebook page and
then she was from her official facebook
page and some responding to a million
people someone said i honestly can't
tell if you're mad or not bestie
and courtney love said she didn't ask so
bit of both i dig manners
so now it's like this overall question
which by the way olivia rodrigo did post
a series of inspiration photos on her
instagram story where she got the
inspiration for this photo
and most of it was from the movie carrie
okay which i think we can see
you know yeah in the photo there you go
so
do i think that this photo was a source
of inspiration i do they're really
really similar looking
but now it's like where this is just
like a question i feel like we talk
about a lot like where's the line
between
copying and inspiring and i feel like
this album from
30 years ago like i don't know if you
can really be copying an album from 30
years ago like if it's that old like it
it's automatically
inspiration if that makes sense you know
yeah i do i don't know i don't
i don't think i have an official opinion
on the matter
no me neither i i actually don't really
care i just um
i think what's worth talking about here
is this courtney love like bullying an
18 year old
yeah no it's definitely a weird way to
go about it for you to get your point
across
yeah but they are similar yeah and you
know like a concept of a beauty queen
like crying is not the most original
yeah it's not like it's a trope you know
like
yeah and if you look thus far like all
of olivia rodrigo's like
imagery for her album it's very much
like angsty teenager like in the good
for you she's like
lighting up the gym on fire while she's
in her cheerleading uniform so there is
this like
high school thing high school rebellion
and prom
does happen in high school yeah
so i don't really feel like it's a big
deal but the comment about
um sending her flowers is so funny yeah
and
i kind of love this like did i think
this year we were gonna get a cordy love
vs olivia rodrigo knockout no i did not
am i upset that we did absolutely not no
once again
no not at all well interesting beef of
the day beef
b-o-t-d [ __ ] your outfit of the day this
is the beef of the day
we need more beef of the day you know
what else we need more of
comfort yes stress relievers
yes therefore we need more by the
logic theory yeah therefore we need more
hush blankets
yes let's talk about the quality of your
sleep the reality is over 160 million
americans struggle with sleep
and hush is here to help hush has a wide
range of sleep essentials for every
sleeper
whether you're a hot sleeper or a cold
sleeper hush has what you need to get
the job done
they carry everything from pillows and
sheets to their best selling weighted
blankets which i have had for over a
year it is
the best and they even have their iced
weighted blankets that keep you cool all
night because if you're a warm person
you get sweaty in your sleep
you might not think that a weighted
blanket is the best one for you but they
have an iced weighted blanket which
literally the technology will keep you
cool all night if you're looking to
improve
your nightly rest naturally hush is the
answer
um they also give back so they
from day one they have donated one in
ten adult blankets and one in five kids
blankets to those in need around the
world so you can feel
good about your purchase you're sleeping
better knowing that everyone is sleeping
better
so if you're looking to upgrade your
sleeve head over to hushblankets.com and
use the code toast for 40
off your next purchase it's valid on all
products again that's hush
blankets.com the code is toast for 40
off it's the biggest discount they offer
so make sure to check them out um
you won't be sorry like my weighted
blanket is still in pristine condition
and i got it over a year ago
and it travels from you know my living
room to my bedroom and it's just
fabulous it's a well-traveled blanket
yes much like
its owner 100 okay next story is a
little annie live casting news that i'm
so obsessed with like i was already
watching any live setting my dvr
jackie okay so before the show started
you were telling me the stories and then
you said
and then i have one annie live story but
i don't want to tell you what it is i
want to surprise you on camera
i thought you said andy live like a
watcher weapons live like special
oh well no honestly i think this is more
exciting okay actually we have miss have
you always have a watch what happens
live special yeah
we have the hannigan played by taraji p
henson and now we have
daddy warbucks oh okay okay um give me a
clue
okay is he bald no okay okay actually
very nice head of hair
oh someone who i am always saying is
like
so underrated jacob charm bloody
no jacob trump like no no no but like
you're getting
warmer oh i am going sort of no
okay give me a different glue okay
someone who is so multi-talented
you probably like wouldn't when you
think of a multi-talent like you don't
know ryan seacrest
no you don't necessarily think of him
but then when you think about him you're
like oh he's done
so many things does he sing yes zac
efron
no older hugh jackman no close oh [ __ ]
oh i'm so excited okay um close okay so
like musical theater right
like who does singing okay i'll give you
more clues and in their roster of things
that they've done they can sing
they can host a daytime show harry
connick jr harry connie jr wow that's
really good in that really good you
love harry gothic jr i just like i i
don't even know his music or anything
that he's crossed my path like his his
talk show i thought was so good he was
great on american idol great on american
idol such good
feedback yeah and just like a nice guy a
hundred percent
and he's gonna be amazing in annie live
here's a question
is he gonna shave his head i hope not
who said that
warbucks had to be bald me i said it
i feel like daddy wore books sorry i
just wanted to be authentic daddy
warbucks could have gotten hair plugs
that's true a lot of time has passed
technology like he has so much money why
wouldn't he
that's true some people like to be bald
like on purpose 100
but maybe daddy warbucks was feeling
insecure he said i want to be a nice set
of hair
oh i'm so happy that's so good so far
we're two for two on
casting like i am so excited about
animals so just remind me because you
know my memory is bad so it's like a
live tv thing
yeah you know how like a grease yeah
yeah but like i think this has the
makings of being fantastic
that's really and you like someone with
a performing background like it's a
like to do those live performances it is
so much like your timing has to be
perfect your blogging has to be perfect
your vocals have to be on point like
it's truly like being on broadway
yeah they need nick jonas he's really
actually good at stuff like that
he is but who i don't know what role
there is for him no but maybe he'll be
in you know another nbc live production
because there's actually like a
a really short list of people in
hollywood who are appropriate for
roles like this who can act sing and
dance and who have a background in
theater
yeah yeah it's not for everyone no it's
an operating brute one but it is for
harry connick junior that is
wonderful wonderful news very happy for
him and
i'm really happy for us because it looks
like i don't want to jinx it it looks
like we have something to look forward
to
it looks like annie live is shaping up
to be quite the production yeah i'm
really looking forward to who they cast
as annie but i don't know that many
child actors it'll be um
i think like a new face because we don't
even there's no obvious
yeah young like all the kids from
stranger things are too grown i'm not
familiar with the space so i don't think
no that red-headed girl from stranger
things like when she was younger
when the show first started she would
have been good yeah even though annie's
like
really young yeah no she's like 10. oh
i think she's like eight yeah i don't
know we'll get a confirmation on that
though
it's super young i do think that'll be a
fresh face yeah i'm excited to see what
camper nabs the role
yeah it's very exciting it is exciting i
hope there's a role
a space for jacob tremlay i do hope
so i do but maybe why can't annie be
anderson so true anderson live
or andy it sounds the exact same
i thought you literally said we were
talking about eddie cohen so that's
so true so harry connick jr okay
okay so we'll keep you updated on all
the annie live casting news this is your
one stop shop for annie live
and olympics coverage and nbc is not
even paying us jackie can i tell you
something sure
i know why you're obsessed with harry
connick jr cher
so when we were on the breath we like
mentioned him once i think we were
talking about american idol how he's
like really handsome like a good judge
and then we were like he has a daytime
show and like his producer reached out
and gave us tickets and literally the
day she emailed us was the day his show
got cancelled
oh man i don't even remember that
doesn't even ring a bell that's crazy
maybe i'm making it up no no i'm not no
i don't think you are i don't think you
would
it's so tough to know you know it's so
tempting and when you're not here to
fact check like you don't remember what
i'm talking about there's really no way
maybe you were going to surprise me with
the tickets and so you never shared
i mean i don't have access to my old
email anymore because i was fired
but if i did i bet you i could find it
or maybe she emailed me personally let
me check hold on
okay how do you spell conic
c-o-n-n-i-c-k
harry i'm telling you n-n-n-i-c-k
hmm it's not looking good i don't know
like you know
your phone yeah no it's uh
it's not it's not here okay well it is
what it does maybe we'll get tickets to
annie live
yeah like enthusiastic so cool we're
like literally the biggest supporters
i agree i haven't heard anyone else
talking about it so if it weren't for
you i literally would not even know that
this is a thing
i mean it is really early stages like
the whole place hasn't even been
captured i haven't even been rehearsing
there's no annie like
yeah so i guess it makes sense why
there's not like a ton of press
yeah but still we can get we can be
excited about something of course
normalize being exciting about things
like
life is all about having things to look
forward to 100 because i actually
woke up today and i was like you know
what i'm not even going to complain that
it's monday like we have a holiday leave
july 4th
and honestly after this we don't have
anything until august for
labor day but you know what we do have
in between the olympics
and my birthday thanks for remembering
um yeah like
and you know what we have before labor
day bruno's birthday now that's going to
be something to celebrate
so all i'm saying is like life is it's
true life is all about just like getting
to the next thing you have to look
forward to it and currently we need to
acknowledge the space that we're in
we have a bunch of like you know federal
holidays coming up we have
a few days off of work we have life
experiences to look forward to
normalize like planning your life around
things you look forward to 100
i think a lot of people do either
inadvertently or you know
advertently or consciously like us like
i really think that's how i live my life
just like
what's the next thing i'm going to be
excited about which is why i think kobe
was so hard
yeah because there was nothing to look
forward to and not even like the idea of
like okay well in a
in six months yeah like it was just a
one big question mark no and the things
that like
were the equivalent of what we're
looking forward to like we did like
these fun saturday night zooms like it
was really hard to get excited about
that
really really hard like painstakingly
difficult yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story something else to look forward to
a little podcasting news
is it the final story
stopped
[Laughter]
um felt good you know what we kind of
took the shame out of it you know
no i feel so good about it like i know
people love it so much
and for me like this show is a journey
you know we
we start out hi good morning millennials
there's ups and downs and like by the
fifth story peace and values you could
be fatigued but that
final story song is the serotonin boost
that we need i feel strongly you know i
feel like sometimes when you're
listening to a podcast you like kind of
days out and you like miss a couple
minutes
but then this song brings you right back
into the final story 100
and the final story is usually pretty
mindless so
no i feel like the final story is always
well business or food or
yeah just like something that you can
bring up at the dinner table but this is
actually
just some more celebrity news podcasting
news tana mojo nabs a multi-million
dollar podcast deal
youtube star tana mojo has nabbed a
multi-million dollar podcast deal to
launch and host a podcast called
cancelled with tana mojo um i think
actually uh
we have the trademark to the word
canceled in partnership with the paragon
collective and dwe talent page six can
exclusively reveal
they're told mojo's cast will cover pop
culture and current topics and will
feature influencers and celebrities
talking with her in her newly built west
hollywood studio she said i'm finally
ready to talk about everything and when
i say everything i mean everything
i've had many offers to do my own
podcast but now is the time to open up
the vault
i mean i have recently become like a
intrigued by tana mojo
um and i watch her youtube videos yeah i
watch her youtube videos but they're so
inconsistent
like she just doesn't have i don't think
like a rhythm and a frequency and when
she puts them out
so the thing with the podcast is that in
order to be successful like you have to
be really consistent so i'm actually
looking forward to having
tana content every single week yeah do
you think she's gonna film it and record
it because i'm really
a visual person i love a web show i do
feel like more people are filming and
recording now i think like every major
podcast does
yeah so i hope that she does because i
of course would prefer
to watch it as a video and that's
because we were raised down icarly
yeah no but also because like that's
what we do when we do it because that's
what we would want to see
yeah um also i be i became so deeply
intrigued with tana mojo at one point
that i
watched the jake and hannah show on mtv
you did
i watched the first episode like just it
wasn't like jake and tana show you
hannah turns 21. yes yes yes but jake
was on it yeah because they were married
yeah tana turns 21. that was because
they were married yes exactly
just to see what was going on in the
world of tana no it's very intriguing
like she's kind of all over the place
and honestly even the paparazzi team
bryce on
god like she and she's no like i'm
telling you like i follow her and tic
tac i fell around on these platforms
like i'm kind of obsessed
i'm like larry about to buy her only
fans also i listened to her episode of
call her daddy
oh yeah and it was so good so much to
say yes i watched it
so much to say so good like i think this
is a girl who can talk into a podcast i
think this is a
no-brainer me too i also think it's a
girl who's like lived a lot and they
grew up really fast and i could probably
offer some
insight into all of that and she's like
always going out like
like seeing people meeting people like
she's i feel like she's new stories i'm
surprised we haven't run out of [ __ ] to
talk about when literally all we do is
sit in our house like a hundred percent
there's really not much
content to talk about when you stare at
your tv all day
but we we find a way and it's never been
an issue because wondering why we were
raised on drake and josh
i found a way
drake bell to like endangering a child
to
yeah and it came out that like child
stuff what he was guilty of was
engaging in an inappropriate
relationship online with a 14
or 15 year old that sometimes quote
unquote
turned into a sexual nature but always
online or
i believe it was always online whoa yeah
so that's the follow-up i'm still
waiting on follow-up from the josh
duggar case but that one
is a case for the fbi literally so i
think it'll be a little while longer
before we figure out what happened
yeah your nails look amazing thank you
so much
i've been admiring them this whole time
and i just felt like interrupting you to
let you know that
i love being interrupted and i love
being given
compliments so are they're not press on
they are what
yes i'm telling you i've been telling
you guys about chill house they're the
best person else this is not sponsored
i can now get targeted for press-on
nails i get targeted for chill house
just because i'm your sister
and i'm open to other companies and i
found this really cute one
and you could customize everything 90
for a set of press-on nails that you
have to take off in the end and throw
them out
these are sixteen dollars like you
literally cannot put a price look better
than any ones you've ever done no it
looks like you're like snitch and you
went to gloss
lab and you asked for a cool french
manicure
i know like literally i'm obsessed like
nobody listens and by the way i put
these on before vegas and that one has
fallen off i did a really good job
applying them sometimes i do like a
shitty job you want to get these through
i would try them yeah they're really
cool and you could file them so like
some of mine are a little long i need to
like file them down
they look excellent they give you like a
little buffer and i didn't even know
because i'm so new to the press on game
you can file a press-on nail and make it
the shape that you want make it shorter
make it skinnier like
it's so customizable that's really cool
no i'm obsessed
they look amazing thank you so much um
let's dive into the tv recap because i
have a few things i want to talk about
which is brought to you by honey we all
shop online and we've seen that promo
code feel taunt us at checkout but
thanks to honey manually searching for
coupon codes
is a thing of the past because honey is
the free shopping tool that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one it finds to your cart
honey supports over 30 000 stores online
they range from sites that sell tech and
gaming products to popular fashion
brands
i've used it for clothes for makeup for
tech like i've used it on everything
i've been using honey since before they
were a sponsor because the toasters told
me about it it's literally free money
like just do it
basically how it works you're shopping
online when you check out honey will
drop down and all you have to do is
click apply coupons and they'll do all
the work for you
they scour the internet find the best
code that'll save you the most money
um and it's actually a no-brainer
because if you don't do it you're
just like wasting money no literally if
you like to shop or someone say if you
like to invest
yeah you need honey i recently even just
was buying makeup online
honey hooked it up promo codes free
samples
everything of the sort so it's free to
download when you go to joinhoney.com
so if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings it's free and installs in a few
seconds
by getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting the toast when you
go to joinhoney.com
toast that's joinhoney.com toast
love it thank you for that claudia okay
so i watched all of working moms season
five
on um the plane to vegas it was they're
so
short episodes and it's ten episodes i
love the show i really really do
um i felt like some of the seasons have
been better than others this one was
really good except it's one of those
seasons
where you're watching one of the main
characters just like go down a dark path
and like make all the wrong choices
so i can't remember any of the women's
names um
anne who is like not a main character
but she's always been my favorite it was
kind of like her season like she gets
this book deal
and she's just like making bad choice
after bad choice after bad choice like
spoiler alert she's a psychologist and
she starts
um like hang out in a bad crowd in this
new town she moved to
then she hits her book deal and she's
just like making bad decisions it was
just like
really frustrating to watch and i hate
shows like that where it's like
everything goes wrong before it has to
go right you know
um but it's just like a really good show
it's such a weird show it's like
canadian and it's like not even popular
but i love it and netflix like brought
it to the states
it's very like shit's creek vibes in
that sense it's really good i actually
think you would like it
i you guys told me about it olivia loves
it yeah and
loves it because she's a working mom i
put on season one once and
five minutes in i i didn't like it but i
didn't give it a chance to be honest
it's easy and fun i wouldn't say it's
something you have to watch okay
but i do enjoy it okay thank you for the
honesty then i watch too hot to handle
and it's really i like forgot about it
it's such a good show but it's really
interesting to watch
now that the show got so popular it's
harder to trick them
because remember the first day they get
there they think they're going on like a
love island type of show and that
they're just going to be
[ __ ] and drinking all weekend i mean
all summer and
it was harder to trick them so this time
they went to extreme lengths
they told them they were going to be on
this show called parties in paradise
they had a fake host
who was jeff dye is that the guy chris
and cavallari
was dating yes yes so he's like the fake
host until
the robot comes and you know [ __ ]
everything up and i thought it was so
interesting they had to really go out of
their way
to not let people think that it's at a
new location like yeah because the show
is so popular
it was easy to trick them the first time
you know but that sounds like they were
able to trick them again there are so
many reality shows yeah and they really
went to like
extra lengths to um
fool the people and i think that they
were all like 100 fooled that's awesome
yeah it was really well done and the
jeff dive it all was like
just too many pop culture intersections
happening for me it was overwhelming
i'm only two episodes in but there's a
lot of like really really pretty girls
and really hot guys obviously that's the
point of the show
that they are too hot to handle yeah and
it's good i don't know if it's going to
be as chaotic because
i don't get the vibes from anyone yet
that they're just like willing to break
the rules like that was like francesca
and that girl haley like they were just
like
[ __ ] [ __ ] up for everyone yeah
there's really i'm not getting that
energy but i'm only two episodes in so
they might
come along you know they do send new
people right
i don't know i have like a vague
recollection of like three people
showing up on a boat
last year yeah yeah yeah yeah so you
never know and we just are getting to
know these people but there's
it's an interesting crowd and i like
that they cast people from all around
the world so it's like really different
vibes to personalities cultures like
it's it's really uh
a good way of doing a show there's like
people from florida and there's people
from
ireland like it's good um and i think
you'll enjoy it
it's really like a good show and netflix
does reality tv very very well yeah it's
easy watching
it's such easy watching i'll finish the
first draw probably today
okay maybe i will too though i have to
finish the nature of fragile things i'm
really like looking forward to finishing
it i'm not
like just trying to speed read i really
want to enjoy it because it's so good
you know it's just a good hearty book
and is it
let me check my watch is it too late too
oh no become a redhead
i'm worried it's not too late because
it's never too late to become a redhead
ever if you think like no brad it's not
for me i don't read
why not treat yourself read an amazing
book change your perspective on some
stuff
change your perspective on things yeah
um well
that's what i watch you have any tv you
want to recap or is that our show i
think that that is our show i was
i tried to start something on thursday
night before i went away
um like a a period piece a period piece
and i was just
it wasn't for me it was called the
collection it was like post-war
paris and i was just like nah i watched
the first episode enough to be like nah
well that is our show you guys happy
monday and i hope you all have a great
day thank you so much for listening to
the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the past five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube
so if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found anywhere
anywhere so it's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i have rated cash box
all the places so whenever you listen to
podcasts find out some more you chose
leave a five view about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you guys
have an amazing day we'll see you
tomorrow for tuesday's show
and more positive vibes yes for sure
goodbye goodbye
you